thank you
[Music]
all right a very disturbing statistic
came out and I don't know
um if I have the data to corroborate on
whether or not it's true so maybe some
of you guys do is this habits or sexual
it's sexual how did what it made you
pick between those two because
everything's sexual and everything is
yeah like two out of five people don't
floss or whatever let's go how to make a
[__] kind of hard
I need to learn that one yeah what's
your secret Steve the trick is to smack
it yeah on the outside I just clenched
that's hard ouch like that is that
correct trust me on this do you do it
like
like an aggressive preacher holding his
Bible
he's a southern creature Southern
Baptist dinner up on the table right
yeah yeah oh yeah I'm gonna smack that
little [__] around
they love it was that your sex voice we
just heard that's okay that's my bedroom
boys
you want to go on a tangent and see what
do you think Anthony Lee does Anthony
Lee what he does yeah since his
girlfriend's laughing
[Laughter]
guaranteed he he gets on top of her and
wraps his legs around her like he's
hugging the toilet foreign
according to a recent study it's been
found that 70 of guys cheat during their
bachelor party
boy finish your clap I heard two claps
finish the whole fun okay I thought
that's what you're supposed to do okay
that's interesting because
that's
that's kind of a misconception yeah is
it cheating though if it's a hooker
questions because some people have
different rules what if she's not alive
if she's a dead hooker is that cheating
well because in this case and you didn't
kill her
are these guys just like going out on
Bachelor parties and then they're just
getting laid like they pick up a girl
and they're just like one last time well
let's start there like what what do you
see like what's a bachelor party spider
kill it
what's the best report is supposed to
turn teacher it's going back the other
way can we clip that dude teacher this
is my favorite thing I've ever received
teacher okay yeah what sorry don't
forget me so for me like you know like
all if you talk to any lawyer they'll
say the language the legal language
whatever at the end of the day is to
best Express intent right like that's
what they're trying to do
so for me I'm like then the intent is
the most important thing so if the whole
point of a bachelor party is the [__]
while out one more time before one last
time you put it locked down yeah yeah
then you might as well [__] your brains
out half an orgy like [__] go do all
the Coke in the world yeah uh that's
what a bachelor party should be for all
right and when I found out that it's
frowned upon to do that then I was like
I don't want to have a bachelor party so
I didn't have one oh you know what I
mean I was like you did it would have
been that type if you did you would have
found out during the bachelor party that
it's frowned upon I think yeah yeah I
got the professional party like and then
they're like oh this is from the bond
you're like what people are frowning at
him
visible frowns everywhere everyone's
looking so I was like that's weird I'm
not gonna show you that what's the point
of a bachelor party then yeah that might
be the point there's a bachelor right so
as a bachelor's be able to do all kinds
of crazy [__] I think it's for the I
think it's for the groom party I think
it's more
except for you no no I'll say this all
the groups
when I when I got married every all my
groom has been were like so what are we
gonna do for the party I was like I
don't want to have a party and they're
like no we're gonna have a parties and
they just keep pushing it but what did
they mean by party everyone they want to
go to like a strip club they want to go
[__] get drunk or whatever yeah
everyone's definition that's [__]
Dental damn type [__] that's what I'm
saying you're [__] licking the [__]
with the [__] Saran wrap on your face
my favorite way to eat [__] yeah I
don't want you need to [__] catch
Chlamydia that's what I'm saying
something I agree I agree if you're
gonna do it you might as well do it
bachelor parties don't feel special why
because it all of those activities I
could do whenever I want I'm married or
not
and that's
that's the strip club that's
okay for me I think
I think after parties are first it's
cheaper on Wednesday exactly I think
they're for dumb people yeah to be
honest Bachelor parties are like hey you
guys want to waste so much money all
right to be honest if it was a real
bachelor party I wouldn't even mind
making out with the dude
isn't it cheating even before you're
married while you're in the relationship
nah but then they do the whole
soundtrack you sign legal documents
because before you're married you're
single if you're not gay but you kiss a
guy and you're married you're good dude
you go to Italy that's confused these
are really convoluted these are these
are Italian rules what's the Italy rule
you go to Italy and you have a boyfriend
girlfriend okay Italian guys will hit on
your girlfriend all the time
because they're like wow come on you're
not married
true
one of our Italian clients right she
tells she's the one that told me this
she's straight from from Sicily she
talks with her hands
and then she goes yeah if you're if
you're not married
they're gonna try to have sex with your
girlfriend you guys say that [__] all
the time where's your ring where's your
ring
where's your boyfriend I could come home
with me then you know so that's how it
goes I'm not saying that's how I see it
that's just the way yeah you're right
he's not giving me a ring and [__] so
[__] this [__] it yeah once you sit on
my face then how do you feel about
Bachelor parties I think you guys are
talking about like semantics like what's
the label whatever but if I'm saying the
language exactly so it doesn't matter if
you're single married together it's it's
the you care about somebody would this
hurt them yeah that's why you don't have
a bachelor party do you believe in some
Bachelor parties getting a pass like hey
go ahead and do whatever you want if
that's what you agree upon then yeah but
what if like I do care about you but
you're taking this really seriously
hahaha
I'm cheating
oh yes the right questions depends on
the couple
because some some wives will be so
generous as to say [__] aren't
cheating that's true that's generosity
who's that who's saying Hillary Clinton
said that that's it
did she really say that she's a standard
I think verbatim um
69th Amendment yeah
nope you don't get any of those can you
say that one more time did do you have
any of those Liberties in your marriage
mine yeah nope none you never campaigned
for any of those
I don't want to yet yeah it's not the
right time he's waiting go to a strip
club oh yeah yeah so that's not cheating
some people wouldn't want
oh I remember you said you went to a
bachelor party with your dude and he had
quite a bit of fun how many lap dances
do you think is is cheating
okay yeah like so like your guys it's
bachelor party like how many do you
think is appropriate for a bachelor
party weekend and how many do you think
it approaches well don't you eventually
run out of money though because like
unlimited money you have unlimited money
I think on average I've people probably
get like around five
I feel like the wife got to Define that
how many how many do you think yeah zero
zero see this guy so what if it's double
digits what if it's what if it's 14
[__] times dude I love it literally
14. left in times this [__] kept
on going wait lap dances are cheating to
you
so would you would you have
feelings against your boyfriend going to
the strip club
what if he went by himself oh that's
weird
what if it was at like noon you know
because there's there's even socially
acceptable they're socially acceptable
like strip club etiquette right because
I feel like these words yeah silk pants
with excessive amounts of lap dances
that's weird and he's always adjusting
the front of his pants all the time
having his hands in his pocket the whole
time and not buying lap dances is also
weird yeah yeah yeah you know what
though I do agree with your thing where
you said it's for the it's for the uh
groomsmen because they do egg on a lot
of that stuff I I think it is like let's
say that it's your last chance man
they're the ones that are trying to
escape last chance to do nothing come on
dude nothing's happening dude you're
gonna be locked away how would you act
towards Anthony if you were a groomsmen
at his bachelor party what would you be
like egging him on to do
to stop [__] dudes if you could
I if you could take a minute and hang
out with the boys
and Anthony is like tired bro he's
not myself I gotta get out of my system
yeah sure [__] dude for a minute just
hang with the boys we all came here
where are we it's like what is it's your
bachelor party we haven't seen you all
night so okay I'm shocked at the number
but I'm also
I'm also not that um
shocked because the type of people that
want to do Bachelor parties what I think
when I think of that I think of just
like a dude's dude that likes to go to
the weekend like they drink like they
all cheat it like this isn't their first
time okay I see what you mean you know
what I mean like these guys are those
guys right yeah yeah and then so like
because think about it in our group how
many of us had Bachelor parties and then
if when we did how [__] wholesome
were they mine was right I didn't have a
bachelor party because we couldn't go to
a whorehouse I didn't have one either no
her house party yeah
I didn't want to get burned or [__]
but stay not if you're gonna get yeah if
you're gonna play with fire you're gonna
jump the strip clubs to me you're like
oh there's a flame oh look what I could
do oh I might just [__] burn yourself
I've never heard that I'd rather get
burned or stay not burnt
that I understand that yeah no I get it
I get it what was your wholesome batch
we went to went to Vegas we got a suite
like at the cosmo or whatever okay it
was sick and like we we went to like
restaurants and just like did like a
little bar call kind of that sounds fun
yeah we didn't like I was like no strips
no stripper stuff only because my buddy
was like in like a 10-year relationship
with oh so he didn't want to get in
trouble you want to get in trouble I'm
with Nikki I don't wanna I'm not into
that I'd rather do that just take the
sexual part out of it like why play
dance with this sexual fire just let's
just go [__] ride ATVs in the desert
like there you go there's some other
[__] yep and
the the type of people you see on
bachelor and bachelorette parties in
Vegas like or party towns and you see
them in the group but the matching
t-shirts yep you're like they're all out
here to cheat like they're all out here
to like [__] and get drunk
there's there's a lot of that right and
[__] if you got matching t-shirts though
with a bunch of dudes
you can tell you can tell yeah yeah
but I don't know I I feel like
um
we were talking about this yesterday but
a lot of people just settle in their
relationships anyways so to me I don't
even think that relationship was sacred
in the first place that's why 70 of them
cheating it's the majority dude that's
true so true that's on JK overtime yeah
coming soon and they probably continue
throughout the marriage I wouldn't be
surprised it's like you're starting it
stained like that interesting uh stat if
we can get out of those guys that
cheated at their bachelor parties what
percentage of them continued to cheat
exactly all of them probably yeah
[__] percent yeah yeah unless they
got caught
I mean I got the buddy who definitely
was just a cheater in general and like
he would use Bachelor parties as a way
to like wild out a little bit but like
he was already so that's why he's the
guy that's egging on his buddies
so now nobody's that influences yeah you
don't you're not as guilty because
everyone else is doing the guilty thing
yeah it's a whole group of people doing
it yeah so it's like going down with a
ship kind of a idea interesting okay
that's my theory and then some of these
things are super elaborate too because
like we know
um guys out there they'll be like oh
we're going on a [__] shipping trip
uh we're gonna go on a fishing trip in
Colombia it's like oh I didn't know
Colombia had great tuna exactly dude and
they all they all go out on a fishing
trip but magically they're in a mansion
like with a room full of hot hookers and
cocaine we're going to Thailand for the
food uh-huh you're going to food
crawling Thailand food crawl yeah yeah
yeah okay I went to a bachelor party
with a guy in Palm Springs and then we
ended up going on
um a vacation with together like as
couples like newly married okay and this
cat not kidding we were we just get to
where we're vacationing and he's like oh
my God I would have had such a good time
here when I was single he said that out
loud next to his chick in the car that's
[__] crazy dude my every [__]
orifice my body clenched and I was like
oh God and yeah there's everyone just
like yeah they didn't make it they
didn't even make it like three four
years I think is when they got there but
they're married though they were married
but then that was a newlywed thing dang
I mean that's a pretty stupid mistake to
make even if that was his real thought
like why say that I say it out loud and
why say it like a forlorn puppy looking
through a window it was like rain on the
glass he was longing dude yeah dude it's
because he was using past tense it feels
like hey babe can we pretend like we're
not in a relationship for like two days
then it's more present yeah yeah okay
then you could do what you want to do
see that's a good work around that's
right